has got 19.
working his way inside nice little move
two right there by karis laverch
and garrett trent jr is reluctant
[Applause]
in the corner this is carmelo anthony
first hit from the field since the
second quarter
oh it's a foul inside
it goes on carmelo anthony who just hit
that three right there mellow now has
five revert with trent on him
oh a series of fakes in this beautiful
and he gets the two on that move
tapped around picked up by mccullum
under three to go
down court nurkic and with his size he
gets it and spin
market just got 20. levert's got 32.
spinning inside fatal good as well
he's willing
[Applause]
one point brooklyn lead down court trent
three
oh he's a flame thrower what a shot by
trent outside
three
who is going to blink smaller brooklyn
team with all these offensive rebounds
scouted and flies inside foul on harris
county for two don't have the size down
low
whiteside nurkic has owned
the paint cabaret gets the loose ball
gets it off to levert pound it all what
a defensive play by
lillard he stole the ball what a play by
lillard two point lead minute to go
[Music]
cj mccollum with 23
19 foot check card
big hit by c mccullum the lead is
four another offensive rebound allen
volleyballed it back a new shot clock to
work with
here comes levert in doubled up in town
second shot opportunity here for the
nets and it's levert
lakaris lavert with five seconds left
levert
going for the win his jumper no
no good portland wins and escapes
to clinch the 8th c
is an opportunity as the nets go for the
win
that will forever continue to motivate
him and drive the player we know karis
levert to be
[Applause]
didn't want to extend the game said he
was
going to win or go home and levert
could not quite get it to go as damien
lillard looks around at the clock and
knows
we've done it down by one levert for the
lead
it's over and portland survives
the portland trail blazers survive
and they will play in the play-in game
with lillard putting in 42 and mccullum
putting in 25
and levert had a chance to give him a
lead in the win
finishing with 37 an
exhausting and emotional game with two
terrific opponents tonight